hello everybody I'm really excited to be
talking to David Pakman today David
Pakman of course is from the David
Pakman show he's got a great channel on
YouTube he's also a nationally
syndicated radio host as well and I
believe are you still on free speech TV
as well David
we are indeed yeah 11:00 p.m. Eastern
Monday through Friday so he's uh he's
everywhere
he's uh he's been doing this for a while
very successful youtuber and host so
Dave and I are talking today because we
both stumbled across an article that
this really caught my eye and if I'm
being completely honest with people it
got me pretty angry because basically
this vais article was essentially a snub
of progressive liberal YouTube hosts and
and new media hosts so I'll just give
everybody the title David and then we'll
start talking about this but the name
that the title of the article was why
the write dominates YouTube there's a
lot to discuss in just that so what are
your initial thoughts I was interested
in the article just because anytime that
I see a headline I assume like oh this
is going to be interesting there's going
to be data there will be fact there will
be comparisons of channels and and I was
curious over how do you define what is
the right on YouTube and what's the left
none of that stuff was in the article
and the article basically has a
screenshot of Paul Joseph Watson who I'm
sure a lot of our viewers know is
associated with without Jones and
Infowars
and it mentions PewDiePie at one point I
have no idea how PewDiePie fits into an
analysis of whether the left or right
dominates YouTube yeah uh but it was it
didn't really say anything with fact and
that's what first caught my eye yeah so
on title alone I was furious but then
when I read the article I was even more
furious because like you say by the time
they gets a PewDiePie in the article I'm
like okay what is going on here because
I what what the author was trying to do
and by the way the author's name is Tom
Wyman but
he was like trying to lump PewDiePie
into the right-wing box because of the
recent Wall Street Journal piece on
PewDiePie which was you know he had made
some some controversial jokes but as a
result of that they're like people are
just defining him as a political
youtuber and somebody who's like
forthright about that stuff when as far
as I know I don't watch PewDiePie at all
really but people my audience might know
I think he's just like a gamer right and
every now and then he might make a
comment here and there but his politics
are fairly indecipherable I don't know
if anybody could really say for sure
he's a right-winger but in the article
they just kind of lump them in into that
category which shows you we're dealing
with somebody who basically is just kind
of giving their opinion and they don't
they don't know whether they're coming
or going yeah it sort of seems like the
author feels that the right is
dominating on YouTube but beyond that I
don't know and I agree you know my
familiarity with PewDiePie is limited to
probably 3 to 5 articles I've read about
him and you know one video I looked at
whatever whatever the guy's politics are
it's clear it's not a political channel
and I think that that's why it doesn't
really fit into this article at all yeah
so I want to give one of the quotes here
from the article it says quote on
YouTube left-wing voices are seemingly
non-existent right seemingly - whoo yeah
and it's like when I read that I could
feel the slap across my face I can feel
a slap across your face I can feel the
slap across tyz space so yeah but and
actually you know what I actually have
some numbers here that I want to share
with you because this really gets into
the crux of it which is the article that
could have been written or perhaps
should have been written if somebody
were to talk about this in a serious way
so let's do some comparisons TYT now
love them hate them whatever there's a
lot of people with various opinions and
our audiences about that but they have
3.4 billion views on their main channel
alone the closest you know competitor to
them and they would probably take issue
with even having this person in the same
category but you could say you know a
right-wing version is Alex Jones and
Alex Jones it we're it's like oh he's a
weird
mix of right-wing beliefs he says he's
libertarian but to me when I watch him
all I see is just mostly conspiracy
stuff but he he has 1.2 billion views so
he's significantly behind TYT my channel
has 303 million views a poll poll Joseph
Watkins prison planet he has 182 million
views 10 Watson we want to ice a walk-in
do I say okay I don't want the trolls
raining down anyone no matter what
they're going to come after us for this
but it's okay
we're used to it thick skin and you have
221 million views you're crushing steven
crowder who has 138 million you're
crushing stefan molyneux who has 157
million so I don't almost buy by any
metric is if you're going by the the
most objective metric which I would
argue is total views not only are we not
non-existent we were winning yeah and
there's a couple other things here and
you know the thing is this is an article
that lacks data and we're now talking
about data so it's sort of going to
start to get a little bit into the
logistics of how YouTube works and stuff
that may be of interest or may not but
there's a couple different ways you
could sort of evaluate what's being said
here and I get I don't know if you get
messages like this from people on social
media but I'll get messages from people
who say dude even though you're trying
hard X youtuber is crushing you and
sometimes I'll ignore it and sometimes
out of curiosity I'll pull up not that
this is the best tool but there's a tool
called social blade that you can look at
and it'll sort of give you current
subscriber and view data as well as
projections based on recent numbers in
blah blah blah and you know you'll see
these big subscriber numbers six hundred
thousand seven hundred thousand but you
don't really get traffic from
subscribers unless the subscribers are
watching your videos you also don't make
any money from subscribers unless people
are actually watching your videos and
like you pointed out if you look at and
this is not a penis sized contest right
it's just I say it is for me but not for
you
that may be fine but the point is it
when you look at the views that these
channels get very often I'll see that
these are relatively small channels and
it's not about arguing with people on
social media but it's about let's
establish what we mean when we say that
there is an audience or there is not an
audience there are many ways that you
can get people to click the subscribe
button on YouTube but that's not an
audience yeah and even so even granting
all those people those points the the
main thesis of the article is still
factually incorrect so if somebody were
to say you know what I don't care that
you think I'll that overall views is the
best way to measure it I think that
subscribers the subscribers is the best
way to measure it okay well then if you
go by that metric sure steven crowder
has me steven crowder has you a present
planet has us and that's a different
metric you could use where you say you
know what they're beating you but
remember the point of the title of the
article is why the write dominates
YouTube I'll tell you one thing for sure
we ain't getting dominated and second of
all again a quote from the article on
YouTube left-wing voices are seemingly
non-existent that's just totally not
true and also let's remember again the
Young Turks regardless of what people
think of them they're by far and away
number one in left media right media all
political media especially when you talk
about YouTube so I don't know what this
guy was smoking but I want some because
it sounds like quite a trip that he was
on there's also a fundamental difficulty
with even doing something like this
because at what point does a youtube
channel that's associated with a broader
brand no longer count as a youtuber and
now they're part of corporate media I
don't know where the line is right at
what point are you under the umbrella of
being left or right if you're an
authoritarian leftist versus a
libertarian leftist or a libertarian
right is which which umbrella are you
under I don't even
that I understand how we would be able
to agree on the terms required to make
this data-driven yeah and he said
something in the article about why he
thinks the right is in his mind
you know crushing on YouTube and he
basically says like well you know
they're they're inherently authoritarian
and so one person talking is like
they're they're driven to that and they
like that and it's like well okay again
hold on it doesn't really make much
sense because like I said by some
measures we're actually winning
so is your is your thesis now that would
the left is more inherently
authoritarian like I don't it just it
doesn't seem like there's any real
standard that he's using it really is
just all in his mind and furthermore
yeah like you you made a good point
there about the authoritarian left and I
would argue that to the extent that the
right is doing well on YouTube or people
who can be viewed as the right but maybe
aren't necessarily right it would be
because there's a lot of coverage now
and focus on the authoritarian left or
social justice warriors as they're
called and that get that generates a lot
of views and a lot of cliques I mean you
cover social justice warriors I cover
social justice warriors it's not like
you know we shy away when there's
somebody on the Left who's shutting down
a speaker on a college campus you know I
pretty routinely in fact I would argue
maybe 100 percent of the time have sided
with the speaker even if I think the
speaker is odious so I think that again
there's a category problem like you
alluded to where in the mind of the
person who wrote this article they might
lump in the amazing atheist as somebody
who is a right winger on youtube you
know what I mean yeah and by the way
what you just mentioned maybe think of
this Tommy Lorenz story Lord Lauren I
never know how to say her name as far as
shutting down an encouraging speech may
be a topic for another moment but the
the moment and by the way I don't know
the author of this article and I I'm
going to assume that he's a awesome guy
and very genuinely nice person and had
all the best intentions just to get that
on the record whether
not the article suggest that I'm right
in saying that the moment in the article
where I thought it could have gone in an
interesting direction was the moment you
just talked about which is starting to
think about why certain platforms or
venues lend themselves to better
replication of either left or right way
ideas it couldn't gotten pretty
interesting at that point and I've
talked about this a lot what is it about
commercial talk radio with a 37 minute
hour and 23 minutes of commercials that
lends itself to the right wing idea on
taxes versus the left wing idea on taxes
and it's pretty clear left-wing ideas
Hey tax relief taxes are a burden you
root you lift the burden and now you are
relieved the left-wing position has no
opposite to that because it's not hey
more taxes the better it's well we need
to consider the role of government and
providing somebody blah blah blah blah
blah yeah so there's a really good
conversation to be had there about how
the new forms of media like YouTube and
Twitter for example lend themselves
better to left or right wing ideas
article didn't go there though yeah yeah
that's a very difficult thing to do to
parse through all the data on those in
on those different mediums so like when
it comes to Twitter I probably would
have said 2 or 3 years ago like oh yeah
the left dominates Twitter as this guy
argues in his piece like all the left is
on any Twitter today I wouldn't
necessarily say that and I haven't seen
any hard data on that so I'd actually be
hesitant to even say that the left
dominates Twitter you know the default
my kind of default based on no data
which is a gut feeling when I look at
Twitter now is like it seems about 50/50
to me and to the extent that maybe the
less does dominate it I would argue
maybe that is more to do with
demographic reasons that younger people
tend to use Twitter and you know
statistically younger people tend to
lean more left
but yeah you make an interesting point
about talk radio there - that it was
dominated especially like in the 1990s
when it was Rush Limbaugh and all that
it was dominated by right-wing talkers
and I'm curious how much of that is
first of all just the fact that it was
apparently conservatives who were just
more likely to listen to AM radio but
also I wonder how
much and maybe Mike Malloy would have
something to say about this Tom Hartman
would have something to say about this I
wonder how much corporation's kind of
silenced on purpose left-wing voices
it's not so much so it's interesting
you're mentioning this I've got a new
project that I'm going to be talking
about soon and I've been reading more
academic writing about this issue and
there's this book waves of rancor which
is an academic look at media ownership
right-wing media hate groups etc there's
a systemic bias and ownership bias that
exists if you think about if you think
about the 90s and especially mid to late
90s which could be argued to be sort of
like the golden era of right-wing talk
radio and significant growth the talk
radio if you think about what it costs
to run a traditional radio station which
you and I don't really have to think
about because media has changed so much
if you think about it the amount of
money that's required to run it the sort
of regulatory issues that you may have
to deal with if you own a radio station
depending on who's at the FCC by its
very nature it's going to lend itself to
right-wing ownership and you may have
right-wing ownership that says as a
product I want a liberal right message
right editorially but by and large if
you look at the situation that lends
itself to the ownership structure you
understand it perfectly why talk radio
has been dominated by the right for so
long yeah so now yeah now we're touching
on corporate media in general and it you
know in a way that that that's similar
to Noam Chomsky's manufacturing consent
idea which was you know you get a
picture painted of the world that is
basically right in alignment with the
picture the powerful want you to see
because the powerful people with money
owned the airwaves and make up these big
corporations and they're only gonna hire
people who are going to paint that
picture of the world for you now it's
not like a nefarious where you know
there's censorship and I'll beat you
for the head with this if you disagree
with it but there's a reason why there's
like it's like a system of filters where
at the end of the day on the CNN for
example you're going to have somebody
like Don Lemon you're going to have
somebody like Wolf Blitzer who doesn't
rock the boat very much doesn't question
the underlying things in our society
which make it function as it functions
so they're more willing to just kind of
give the vacuous this is what the
Democrats say this is what the
Republicans say I'll let you guys decide
I'm not going to rock the boat too much
and Chomsky at least argues you actually
get a picture of the world that's
painted that's even more what the
powerful want you to see then even in
some cases when there's actual state-run
media you know so and obviously that's
not the case in with every state two
states vary in space or difference I
like you know US media is as subservient
to power as say North Korea but at the
same time there is a point to be made
there that maybe something like the BBC
for example might have more independence
and give you more varying viewpoints
than a CNN would and CNN's picture that
they paint of the world is much more in
alignment with what the u.s. government
wants you to see
then even BBC's is with the British
government and this sort of relates also
to the categorization problem we talked
about earlier with the article that is
the original catalyst for this
conversation which is if you look on
YouTube under news and politics some of
the best performing channels would be
the YouTube channel the YouTube arm of
establishment corporate media does that
count as right-wingers dominating
YouTube or is it really something else
is it an established brand with hundreds
of millions of dollars behind it who has
chosen to use YouTube as a tool like Fox
News's YouTube channel whatever that
contributes to the total views or
subscribers of YouTube news and politics
views should that really be included if
you're doing an analysis of whether
YouTube is dominated by the left or the
right because you're talking about again
a media outlet with the corporate
ownership structure that we're talking
about and criticizing I don't know and
I'm not asking
toric li i genuinely don't know whether
this box do fox news's youtube numbers
count toward the domination of right of
the right-wing on youtube probably not
yeah i'd agree with that for a variety
of reasons i mean i also find it
interesting this is something i've
thought about before and i've even
mentioned on air I feel like YouTube in
many ways is or is a real genuine free
marketplace when it comes to news and
information I mean obviously and there
are other things to their makeup
channels and then it's okay who has the
most views it's a very I mean you start
with zero subscribers and it's all it's
like a libertarians wet dream okay
everybody starts here and then go ahead
just Duke it out and we'll see who gets
the most subscribers at the end of the
day and who gets the most views at the
end of the day and who can generate you
know the biggest audience or whatever
and I if you were to take the host on
take Brian Kilmeade for example just to
pick on him or Steve Doocy
or Wolf Blitzer or any of these people
and you give them a youtube channel
start them with zero subscribers don't
give them the unlimited you know
millions of dollars of backing and just
let them try to make it on their own on
on YouTube I think they would flop
miserably and yeah and but a lot of that
has to do with sort of what's valued in
a CNN anchor or what's expected if
you're the Fox News person who has to
you know put a particular set of talking
points forward when bill Sammon or
whoever the bill Sammon today is that's
writing memos to you the expectations
totally different and adapt I think the
point you're making is it doesn't even
translate to what yeah you need to do on
YouTube ya know it's a totally different
thing and I also get the sense that with
youtubers like I you get a sense that
you you really like what you're doing
and you or you're interested in covering
the news and you're you're fascinated by
it I know I can say the same thing about
what I do even people who I disagree
with you get that sense when you watch
them and it's just like a totally
different beast it's a totally different
animal than like a corporate media if
there were to be corporate media that
you know CNN for example they I think
they get a lot of views on YouTube
they release like 30 videos a day 40
videos a day and each one gets like 400
views or something but you add it all up
over time and it's like oh wow look at
that so yeah it's a totally different
animal completely but you know to go
back to this article here I honestly
thought it was pretty like disrespectful
you're being very nice of a guy and
you're you know yeah I'm like really I
don't know I don't like I find it in I
find it to lack context completely I
mean it just it's throwing out a couple
of assertions in the absence of not only
data which you provided at the beginning
of the segment but also in a total
absence of context but I don't know why
I'm finding it hard to be that upset it
just seems silly like is anyone even
reading this this article like I feel
like most of the reactions to it were to
the to you you and me tweeting about it
yeah well it's funny because people on
the right are actually pissed about it
too but there is about it for a
different reason they're pissed about it
because they view it just like the
PewDiePie thing they viewed it as like
well here we go again
like establishment media trying to take
down these Crusaders on the right who
are just more popular and trying to drag
them down by saying the only reason
they're doing well and they're
dominating YouTube is because you know
right-wing audiences are inherently
authoritarian and there's these angry
white males in front of cameras that are
ranting and so the right is mad at it
for a different reason I'm just I'm
simply mad at it on factual grounds and
I feel like it's part of a bigger it's
part of this bigger thing where they're
really it seems to me at least that
there's a real snubbing of genuine it's
like genuine progressives and liberals
like I was just reading this is totally
unrelated but it kind of links in here I
was just reading earlier and I'll be
covering this on my show tomorrow
there's this new meeting of like top
Democratic Party donors it's not the not
the new like left-wing version of CPAC
that that they recently launched it's
like another thing where all the donors
are getting together I think it might be
called democracy alliance or something
like that and it's like all the
Democrats are getting together to try to
figure out how to combat Trump and
there's this article there are all these
articles written about
and like as I'm looking at that I'm
thinking yeah but hold on now like we
did you as you know we launched this
thing justice Democrats not not you but
you know I was involved in the
co-founding this thing and like the
amount of coverage that got and
definitely the amount of positive
coverage nearly non-existent positive
covers at that got when that actually
has like grassroots support and there
are numbers behind it it's like it was
just totally snubbed and ignored versus
a bunch of billionaires get together who
are big money Democratic donors in fact
they literally say in the article George
Soros is going to be attending this
thing like okay so they named a bunch of
billionaires who are getting together to
all we're going to figure out how to
fight Trump they get more coverage than
literally hundreds of thousands of
people who are organizing to fight back
against it and I feel like that this is
part of the same kind of thing here
where it's like well we're not going to
count the the liberal youtubers the
progressive youtubers we're not going to
count the left youtubers in the same way
that we're not going to count the real
left-wingers who are organizing to try
to beat back against Trump it's only
legitimate when you know it's a bigger
whatever it's CNN its MSNBC it's it's
what Center for American Progress like
only only they count like you don't
count like if you're if you're liberal
and you're progressive and you're
grassroots we're just going to dismiss
you out of hand I don't know how much
experience you've had with the sort of I
I'm kind of think of how to even how to
even say it the media conference circuit
let me just put it really vaguely just
to try to not identify any specific
people or conferences but I've had many
frustrating conversations with
organizers of different types of
conferences that want to be seen as sort
of like the media people doing the
innovation and the really great stuff
we're having at our conference to speak
fantastic great concept right we should
be doing that David you know we were
wondering if maybe you'd be interested
in being on a panel now it's going to be
like the 7:00 a.m. thing on the last day
as a conference which obviously nobody
goes to it's up but you could
like there's currently a moderator and
five other people on the panel and maybe
you could be the sixth person on the
panel to talk about use of online video
for getting out alternatives to
corporate media narratives perfect wow
that sounds great who is leading the
panel who else is on the panel oh it's
this great person who's had huge success
in online video they give me the name I
Google the person they've got a YouTube
channel with 500 subscribers okay and
I'm it's not that I'm upset that I'm
being snubbed in some way right I'll go
to a conference if it makes sense if it
doesn't I won't go as you probably have
figured out we often get the most
mileage from just staying in our studios
and during the show as opposed to being
all over the place percent but I say why
aren't we bringing in the people with
the demonstrable track record in doing
stuff as opposed to somebody that's
probably in the same way that you're
suggesting who's known somebody who's
friends with the conference organizer or
whatever yeah yeah and I feel like
that's certainly part of it but another
part of it might be and it might be the
case for this writer too I don't know
but it might be the case it might just
be sheer ignorance man it might just be
like here this guy is and you know in
his little bubble with his twitter
account with his followers you know he
came across whatever some some prison
planet videos or some Alex Jones videos
and he saw some numbers and he's like oh
my god this is what's happening the
right is dominating YouTube and you know
far be it from him to actually research
and see but the young turks are up to
what David Pakman is up to what secular
talks up to well and there are a lot of
great I just want to give a shout out to
these people real fast because I feel
like they deserve it the Jimmy Doris
channel is exploding the humanist report
is exploding benjamin dixon who
obviously you're very familiar with
exploding so like i don't know i think i
took a little bit more to heart than
even you did you're being very very
senatorial at this what I mean do is
your sense like we've talked a lot off
air is your sense that I've become more
desensitized to trolling criticism and
attacks than you have for some reason I
mean I don't know what that reason would
be I'm genuinely wondering like maybe
I've just become desensitized in some
way I think I just have a show
refuse in general and I you know my
tolerance for [ __ ] is nearly
non-existent
and when I see something like this I
just like I picture myself as like the
editor and I'm like like this is a
fireable offense like we all may say
like you're I mean look I wouldn't
actually do that let me be clear just so
everybody knows but like if you're gonna
write for Vice and vice you know it's
hey we're a new sight when we we cover
things that are happening and I mean
they do some great work they got people
like on the ground in Syria and getting
shot at so don't get me wrong they do
some great work but if you have somebody
write something like this and is just
factually not true I mean I literally
ask the guy to take the article down I
tweeted at him I was like are you going
to correct this are you going to take it
down where you can just leave this up
there it's just your title is factually
incorrect never mind the things in the
article that are incorrect like so I
don't know I'm totally averse to it and
really mad about it did you hear back
from the guy no I didn't hear back from
the guy which is unfortunately it's
coming to be expected even though you
know I have way more Twitter followers
in hand I don't even if the guys
verified and but you know you call
somebody out accurately correctly and
say look you got to either put a
correction or you got to do something
here nothing because there's no
accountability and unfortunately that's
the world we live in and to bring a full
circle to talk about no accountability
in in media here let me just for the
record note that Alex Jones doesn't
believe Sandy Hook happened this is a
mess unlikely so they put up the face of
a guy who is part of Alex Jones Network
and they do an article based on him and
like that network or Alex himself Paul
Joseph Watson doesn't believe this but
you know Alex Jones thinks Andy hope
didn't happen they somehow generate more
coverage than people who have more views
and actually cover things in a fair way
in an objective way like you and I yes
the pinnacle of the argument that the
that YouTube is dominated by the right
is citing one example which does not
believe that Sandy Hook happened which
just really sort of tells you a lot hey
by the way I know we're wrapping up in a
second Twitter verification I now have
it and I would get tons of people saying
David Kyle kolinsky is verified on
Twitter and you're not verified
Twitter so I finally got verified on
Twitter I don't understand what it what
what can I now do that I've been
verified on Twitter oh nothing it's just
an inseparable badge of honor that
people like me like to trot out to be
smug so I remember I literally tweeted
at Jax the guy who's like the CEO of
Twitter for like a month straight every
day where I compared like the number of
subscribers I had on YouTube versus
whatever the population of whatever
country was like Denmark and I had more
than the population of Denmark I had
like three hundred eighty thousand subs
or something at the time and Denmark has
less or one of those tiny Scandinavian
countries and I just tweeted him at him
every day and would be like where's my
verification because I actually got
rejected once for it and I was like I'm
that's ridiculous
like I'm ranked number five in the like
the White House is right above me in it
was during the election like number of
use for political media or something
like that so I was mad about it and I
pestered him and then eventually I got
verified so I think my audience I did a
second on you uh do you do how strongly
do you feel that it was those tweets
that did it uh not at all really because
I I told my audience to like bombard
them and that I'd have done it yeah I
did a segment I was like just tweet jack
and say what are you doing and then they
did it and then that may have worked I
don't know so I need to learn how to use
my verification to be smug oh because I
don't know how to do that I was born
with that it's like the Lady Gaga song
born this way I was born I'm ugh so
alright David great conversation man
thanks so much for uh for doing this I
really wanted to get this off my chest
so we'll talk again soon man this was
fun let's do it alright sounds good man
see